In keeping with his
reality TV
roots, the former
president preempted
any Justice Department
announcement of the charges
against him in a series of post
on his social media network.
And one, just a few moments ago,
he wrote, quote,
I have been summoned to appear
at the federal courthouse
in Miami on Tuesday at 3 p.m..
He goes on to say,
he never thought it was possible
that such a thing like this could happen.
Then drifts
into boasting about
how he won all the votes
in the presidential election,
which we know is not true.
He also wrote in all caps, quote,
I am an innocent man.
Kaitlin joining us now,
our senior Justice Department
correspondent, Evan Perez.
Evan,
what do we know about these seven counts
Well, we don't know the details
of exactly what these seven counts are.
Anderson,
we know that the former president
was on notice.
He knew that he was being investigated
for a couple of particular statutes.
One is seven 93, the Espionage Act.
That's the willful retention
of national defense information.
We know he was also notified
that he was under investigation for 2071,
which is
a concealment
of these documents, government documents,
depriving them
from the use
of federal government officials
and, of course, obstruction of justice.
The question is what other charges,
possible charges?
We know that there are seven charges.
And, you know, again,
the fact is that
this has never happened before.
And this is something that,
you know,
the Jack Smith,
the prosecutors in that office
have weighed for some time before
making this decision.
Everything, including,
of course,
the target letter
that the former president received
only recently
had to go through Merrick Garland,
Merrick Garland, the attorney general
would have had to review this and decide
whether to to allow it to go forward.
So the idea that this this indictment
we don't know
exactly when it was returned,
if it was returned
today, he's certainly
the former president says
he was notified this evening.
It tells us that,
you know,
the Justice Department
had certainly gotten to this stage
very recently, that they knew
they had enough evidence,
they believe they had enough evidence
to bring this to a jury.
And also just talk about
this being in Florida,
the change of venue.
Yeah, no, actually,
Anderson,
this is one of the fascinating things
for us.
We've been following this.
We've seen dozens of witnesses
go to the federal courthouse
here in Washington
and and be brought
before the grand jury here
that was hearing witnesses
again, testimony
with regard to this
and the January six investigation.
And it's only recently that we understand
that this grand jury in Miami
started hearing testimony.
What we heard from Trump lawyers,
including on our air,
was that they believe
there was an issue with venue.
We're told that
this is something
they raised
with the Justice Department,
that they believed
it would be improper
to bring this case in Washington
because any possible crimes,
any accusations against the former
president happened
in the Southern District of Florida.
Which is, of course, where Mar a Lago is
is located.
It appears, Anderson, that Justice
Department officials
eventually got to that point.
They clearly were at some point
thought it would be better
to do it here in Washington,
but then changed their mind
and decided
that Miami is the place
to bring these charges.
Again, we don't know
the exact details of these charges.
But clearly,
you know,
that's why this sudden change of venue
and now we expect the former president
to appear on Tuesday
for his first appearance
before a magistrate in Miami.
Yeah, he said 3 p.m..
Evan, we'll check back in
with you, though, over the next 2 hours.
I'm joined now
by our political and legal analyst,
New York Times.
Maggie, Haberman, former Obama senior
adviser David Axelrod, former
assistant U.S.
Attorney Ali
Hoenig, and Republican strategist
David Urban, one time campaign
adviser to the former president.
Maggie, I want to start with you.
What are you hearing, first of all?
Well,
I think everyone is still in shock
is hearing the news,
both people around the former president
and frankly, people
across the political spectrum,
because we have been hearing
the drip, drip of this case for so long.
His team was prepared
for this to happen
this week,
didn't have information
that it was going to.
Seven counts is a lot.
You know,
we don't know exactly
what all of the charges are yet.
We're going to have to see
what the complaint is.
We won't know
until presumably it's unsealed.
So there's a lot of unknowns.
But this is obviously not
a good development.
And it's one
that he was hoping to avoid listening.
From a legal perspective,
what do you think the seven counts are?
So what do we what do we know
based on what's been presented thus far?
The best indicator
we have so far
is the search warrant affidavit
from Mar a Lago.
And when the Justice Department
went to a judge,
they said we have probable cause
to believe
that three different crimes
were committed,
willful retention
or mishandling of defense information.
That's part
of the Espionage Act
destruction
or concealment of government documents.
And then third, obstruction of justice.
Now, federal prosecutors
can break this out any way they want.
It's possible
we see multiple counts of some of those.
we see
any combination of those
that adds up to seven
it could be that we see other accounts
because what
you put in your search warrant
affidavit may not necessarily be
what you indict on an Anderson.
Bigger picture,
even without seeing the specifics
of this indictment.
I think it's clear
that Donald Trump is in
for the fight of his life.
This is a man who has been sued, deposed,
taken the fifth impeached, twice
tried in the Senate,
investigated by Congress, even indicted
by the state
authorities here in Manhattan,
but being indicted by the Justice
Department is different.
This is a whole different ballgame.
DOJ has way more resources.
The conduct here is going to be,
I think it's safe to say,
more significant
than what he was indicted for
in Manhattan.
The consequences
if he's convicted
are going to be much more severe
than what he's looking at in Manhattan.
What about there was an espionage
charge as a possibility?
Yeah, that
that is one of the crimes that was listed
and that relates to mishandling
of defense information,
not necessarily classified information.
I should note this also,
one of the statutes
that was listed in the search warrant
application destruction
and concealment of government documents
says on the face of the law,
if a person is convicted of this crime,
he's disqualified
from holding federal office.
Now, big thing
we need to know here,
that may not be constitutional.
That's never been challenged in court.
I think there's a good chance
that that would not hold up in court.
Also, I think it's unlikely.
What we don't know
whether this case will be tried
before the election.
And even if it is,
nothing is final
until the appeal is over,
that will not happen.
Until after the election.
David.
David Irving,
I mean, you know,
the former president quite well.
His statement on his social media,
it paints a picture
of how he's going to portray this,
obviously.
But it's you know,
we saw this kind of played out in an ad
that the wolves are coming for me.
Right, that the campaign has put together
and we've heard this,
you know, over and over that
I'm standing between you and them. Right.
That the Justice Department
had weaponized FBI and weaponized.
You know,
one of the points
I think makes it tougher here
is this Espionage Act charge right now.
And we don't know
if that's one of the seven.
Well, I don't know what the seven counts,
but based upon the search warrant, it's,
you know, the Espionage Act
when you paint yourself
and you and you're a patriot
and you
you're the president
of the United States,
I can't imagine a worse phrase to be used
with the president, United States
than the espionage act, when you hear it.
It just it
it makes you sick to your stomach. Right.
And so I think people
will viscerally react to it
differently than than anything else
that he's been charged with so far.
Conspiracy, obstruction.
I think those things
the president can make go away.
And the people who follow the president
won't pay that much attention to
when you push somebody and say
the president's
alleged to violate the Espionage Act,
that just hits differently.
And I think it's going to be tougher,
you know?
Go ahead.
No, I just
I mean, I think a
I still think obstruction
and other charges that might be in
here are still going
to be problematic for him,
maybe not in a Republican primary.
You. No, I don't legally. I agree. Yeah.
I just
but I think that once
he gets to a general election,
as the
the Front-running nominee,
that he appeared in front runner
for the nominee that he appears to be
right now.
If that holds,
if what happened
last time he was indicted happens again.
And it basically is a political boy.
He still faces a problem
explaining this in the general.
Now, he will
then use it as a political cudgel
against Joe Biden.
There's no question about it.
But if you're standing as a Republican
on a debate stage,
if you're being asked tomorrow,
if you're Mike Pence
and you're being asked like, okay,
now what?
Now there's violation
that we still support him
in a general election,
I think the answers are going
to be completely different.
That's just my take on it.
Well, it may be
you know,
the one thing that Donald Trump
probably has taught us
in the last eight years
or so is humility in these discussions
for six years,
I haven't lived inside his head
like Maggie has, but I've always
but it seems to me
there's always been
this interplay
between his decision to run again
and the possibility
that he was going to be indicted
so that he could actually weaponize
his campaign against these indictments.
And I think that's
what we're going to see
just as we did here in New York.
He's going to say,
as you say, you know,
they the they're coming after us.
They're trying to take our voice away.
And, you know, and no one's no
presidents ever faced this before.
They do not
they're not doing it to Biden.
They're not
you notwithstanding the fact
that there is no real relationship
between the two cases here.
But so,
you know, I think it's TBD.
And I'll tell you those not to
question
the courage of those
Republican candidates,
but I think they're going to
they're going to wait
and see how people react to this.
And Trump
and he's meeting
with his political advisers
and not just his lawyers tonight.
He's going to run a full fledged
campaign to try and use his supporters
as his shield and his sword.
Charging Day
was saying about his decision to run made
that this may have been a part of that.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, I don't think it's
the only thing.
I think part of it
is that if he didn't run, he's
not relevant it's a huge opportunity to,
you know, continue
to raise a ton of money
and have events at his clubs
and so forth.
But it's absolutely the case
that he believes that this is you know,
this is something
that he could use a campaign,
a political campaign could be used to say
this case is political,
that everything is political.
We're getting information in dribs
and drabs.
I want to go to Kristen Holmes right now.
Here's some new information Christine,
what have you learned?
Yeah, Anderson,
we have learned
that of these seven charges,
at least one of them is
related to a conspiracy charge.
Now, we don't know
exactly what that means,
but this is something that we believed
the Department of Justice
was trying to prove.
We know they had brought in a number
of lower level aides
trying to claim
to prove this conspiracy theory
that there had been a larger conspiracy
around obstruction of justice.
Now, again, I want to be very clear.
We do not know exactly what
this conspiracy charge is.
All we know so far
is that there are seven charges
and that one of them at least,
is related to conspiracy.
And we also know
that the Department of Justice
had brought
in multiple sources
trying to prove this point of conspiracy.